house i'm challenging you to not flinch
during my reaction video
still drawing those lines instead of
looking at the cards
more juice
lots more juice he has to ask for it
he's choking time to institute the
heimlich maneuver and stop bullying your
child it's impossible
what do you mean it's impossible what is
mac and cheese unchokeable
all right the fact that he's yelling
though makes it a little bit less likely
that he's actually choking if you're
yelling that means you're moving air 10
year old boy screams for his life for no
reason he's autistic severely autistic
okay so a child with autism what we have
is an autism spectrum disorder and we
don't know where in that spectrum this
child lies can't talk can't make eye
contact screaming's probably his way of
communicating yeah you know some
children that have been diagnosed with
autism one of the challenges that they
face is verbal and non-verbal
communication some children don't have
good social cue identification where
they can't understand someone's emotion
by reading their body language or they
can't speak themselves or they choose
not to speak themselves his brain can
filter information it's a constant
assault on his senses i'd scream too one
of the main things that go hand in hand
with asd hypersensitivity sometimes to
light touch sound and remember while
we're only naming the challenges there
are some positives that can come from a
diagnosis of asd some children are super
smart some have the ability to memorize
things way better than the average child
so it's not only about the challenges
it's about the strengths too er checks
throat no obstructions nothing
which means the only symptom was a
scream which is diagnostic of nothing i
completely agree with foreman you have a
child who was diagnosed with autism who
started screaming and the parents are
very worried about it and now they're
doing like this giant workup with
multiple specialists i wouldn't even
know what the consultation would ask of
the specialist stool sampled a check for
parasites blood culture to rule out
infection and a a for lupus because he
screamed i love investigating if there
is an investigation warranted you're
checking for ova and parasites and lupus
you can't order tests willy-nilly
because false positives are really a
thing dust wheat pollen toxin or
something it could literally be anything
because right now your one symptom is
screaming run a lung ventilation scan
lungs are in the chest too right i had a
date last night she screamed should we
spend a hundred thousand dollars testing
her why did your date scream that was a
weird revelation first not this isn't a
veterinary hospital see actually the
veterinary hospital thing is kind of
funny to me because in medicine we
oftentimes say treating kids working in
pediatrics is a lot like being a vet
because sometimes the children if
they're really young can't tell you
what's wrong with them so it's almost
like treating a dog who can't tell you
what's wrong with them either you know
what it's going to be like trying to put
an autistic kid into a nuclear scanner i
don't envy you guys in those cases we do
sedate uh we give medications like
benzodiazepines for temporary sedation
can't you sedate him or something good
if i don't want the test results to mean
anything are they doing a ct if they're
doing a ct you could take the child i
don't know why you said that the test
won't mean anything
[Music]
god did they just break into people's
homes all the time
[Music]
big shocker dad's depressed and they're
getting information on the parents this
is so unethical
[Music]
this workup on a screaming child is
gonna cost 10 million dollars they're
gonna test his sand out of his sandbox
who is paying for this i can't get
insurers to pay for an antibiotic if it
comes in an easy to swallow capsule and
they're gonna get insurance to pay for
sand testing
fecal matter is there a sample we can
look at parents have the smear kit the
kid is constipated go up his rear and
get a smear talk about creating a
traumatic situation for a child for
absolutely zero reason at this time but
somehow because it's a house md episode
he's gonna be right
i don't even know what they're looking
for in this sphere they already got it
over in parasite samples
so what makes fluid fill the lining of
the kid's lungs infection tumor
i feel like i'm one of his students just
yelling stuff out if there's a plural
effusion we have to rule out heart
failure the pleura by the way is the
lining uh that covers the lungs organs
are covered by pleural membranes which
essentially prevents the organs from
rubbing all over each other so like
there's a cardiac membrane there's a
lung membrane get the kidney cardiogram
adam very hard to perform an echo as is
but to perform one on an uncooperative
patient or combative patient even harder
what
what is it is his heart okay
no
echo suggested a conduction abnormality
ekg confirmed it a conduction
abnormality is basically when there's a
problem with electrical conductivity of
the heart so basically in one part of
your heart you have a node that starts
your cardiac rhythm and then it travels
throughout the rest of the heart the
reason it has to travel throughout this
conductive system is because you don't
want the entire heart beating
simultaneously otherwise it's going to
have all the blood just splat against
each other but if you have the top of
the heart beat first and then the bottom
of the heart beats then you can have
like a rhythmical pulsation of the blood
throughout the heart get a lung biopsy
well it took a half an hour to get the
mask on the kid for the lung scan oh i'm
sorry was there somewhere you needed to
be what are they gonna do with
bronchoscopy i don't understand how
they're gonna do a lung biopsy like
interventional radiology what part of
the lung are they gonna test this makes
no sense this is brutal we wanna do a
lung biopsy
lung biopsies usually come back negative
so biopsy a lymph node under the arm
why are they against sedating this poor
child sedate please it will not change
your biopsy results and the child will
not be further traumatized by this
medical experience hope is what's making
them miserable
what they should do is get a cocker
spaniel
dog would look him in the eye wag his
tail when he's happy animal therapy for
children with autism can actually be
quite beneficial there's less judgment
that comes from animals almost no
judgment actually the interaction that
you could have with the animal is so
much simpler that is an easier
introduction to
human interaction which is much more
complex horses dogs that kind of thing
supportive animals really go a long way
for children who have autism not for all
but in some cases no cancer
because
these aren't lymph cells
then what are they okay let me try and
guess these aren't lymph cells so what
did he get a biopsy of a huge sweat
gland an abscess a dermatofibroma oh my
god what could have he gotten oh oh a
teratoma that has hair cells in ah i
can't have no idea liver cells does he
have liver cancer that is metastasized
to his armpit what's the difference
between cancer cells and liver cells why
can one pass through walls but the other
can't cancer cells of damage lets them
grow into blood vessels go wherever they
want so if the liver cells are damaged
liver isn't damaged tests were normal
well tests on a liver being normal
doesn't necessarily mean the liver is
normal because the tests that we use to
check liver function which we call liver
function test is actually a misnomer
they're actually liver inflammation
tests that tell us if the liver is
damaged thereby releasing liver enzymes
and if these liver enzymes are elevated
then we know there's a problem with the
liver however if your liver is so
diseased that it's in the end stage of
liver cancer cirrhosis those numbers can
be normal because your liver is almost
fried and there's no enzymes left to be
had it's not his liver his heart or his
lungs
it's the calcium carbonate in his stool
he was constipated parents probably just
overdid it maybe he ate a bunch of chalk
or
tubs or they didn't do it at all
calcium carbonate's also what's in chalk
oh
sure didn't cause a plural effusion
forget the chalk this kid's got pica
take him to a buffet he's gonna eat the
table pika
it's a condition where you start eating
things that are not edible paint off of
the walls mud show me what you ate
[Music]
some kind of sand fly or sand weasel
inside of that sand it's a micro tumor
started in his lung which caused a
pleural effusion then it metastasized to
his liver which made his slough cells no
it has to be some kind of worm traveling
throughout his body
hey kill the lights
i'm seeing them all the time
what are you looking for he's telling us
what he was seeing telling us exactly
what was wrong with him
drawing them for us over and over again
hello my british nematodes it's not a
tumor foreman it's worms
we said we also said everything else so
i'm not gonna even take credit for it
animal makes potty in sandbox
boy it plays in the sandbox boy eats the
sand
you can probably tell where this is
going by now stool samples were negative
for parasites raccoon round worms are
not excreted by their human host cameron
tested bro stop acting like you knew
about raccoon poop without looking it up
i swear worms spread from his gut to the
rest of his body he attacked his lungs
that's what made him scream i don't even
care that he knew it was raccoon poo
it's the fact that he knew humans don't
release it in their own fecal matter if
that information that ever becomes
useful to me for some weird way i'm
going to send a thank you letter to the
writers of the show they attack his eye
and the muscles surrounding it making
his eyeball do a backflip
laser photocoagulation to fix the eye
and a high dose of benzomidazole to kill
the worms just think about the sequence
of events here a child that's diagnosed
with autism comes in screaming into the
er house immediately starts running
tests on him and finally gets down to it
that he ate raccoon poop from a sandbox
how did we get here i had a unique
patient case myself click here for that
full story doctors kept misdiagnosing
this gentleman see what happens here
click as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]